you know i want to ask you something
because i think
possibly three times i fly around a lot
on different flights and and i think
three different times i just fly around
the world constantly
uh monitoring airline quality but
but i think a couple of times
easily three times i've seen kids
watching like elf
you know on on dvd or something on like
a computer and i realized that that's a
movie that just gets watched over and
over and over again yeah is that is that
weird you must have i mean kids just you
know kids and parents have seen it so
many times kids like it a lot i i've
only seen it once isn't that weird
you really only saw it once yeah well i
think it would be weird if i was just
like watching myself all the time again
i disagree
if it was me i'd be like let's watch me
some more
but that's me yeah so so you when did
you see you just saw it like at the i
just saw it at the premiere actually
really yeah and i missed like my whole
part to like i have like one little like
moment in the movie really
i came back and i'd missed the whole
thing
like you were great you wandered off
during your part well i had to go to the
bathrooms oh wow okay that's
understandable but that's really yeah
you should check it out you're very good
at the movie yeah yeah yeah you know
what you're you're uh you're you're from
los angeles yeah and i don't know i i'm
you know just grew up you know here on
the east coast where right outside uh
boston brookline and what i didn't no
one i knew i didn't know anybody who was
connected to show business but when you
grow up in l.a i've heard that sort of
everybody's in show business or
connected to show business from the time
that they're like five years old is that
true a lot of kids want to be actors in
la i would say and like they have these
like head shots like
have you ever seen like children's head
shots oh yeah they're like four shots
that's that sounded really creepy by the
way
i just looked through children's
headshots
until the police come someone sent me a
head shot of this kid who's like a mini
me they're like look it's baby john
riley
that's great he can play young young
like four like because the thing that
cracks me up about kids head shots is
like and sometimes character actors have
the suit it's like they're like four
they try to like get the like sort of
range of their like like they show like
yeah they show that
like sad and then there's like nerdy and
then there's like put the violin and
sirius and then there's like kid with a
sideways baseball hat they do this thing
where they'll have a regular headshot on
the front and then you turn it over and
it's divided into different squares and
it's like to show you that they can play
different characters but yeah i get that
we get that from adults like people that
want to do character parts in the show
and the front will be a guy just looking
like this normally or like spinning
around like right yeah looking all sexy
just really you know a 65 year old guy
going hey
but then you turn it over and it's like
i can also play an old coal miner oh
there's golden in their house or i can
play a sailor all aboard you know yeah
you think like it just looks like
they're off their medication it's really
weird it's very sad
now uh you're you're in this movie the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy which i
think has been long a lot of people are
eagerly awaiting this movie i know i'm
excited about it
and it feels like i mean the book's been
around for so long and people have been
waiting for this movie and they finally
made it and you shot the movie in in
in britain in london
whenever i'm over there every i mean i
think of the united states as being sort
of celebrity obsessed but over there
they have like every single magazine in
london is about celebrities too but all
about their celebrities weird
celebrities and you flip through these
magazines and you have no idea who these
people are no it was really shocking
because i thought that they would be
like you know sorry my dress what are
you doing by the way are you trying to
get undressed
i can do that game too
it's very distracting
i'm sorry
it's meant to be is this doing anything
for you right here
it's meant to be it's meant to be like
this it looks nice they like it yeah um
i haven't told you about these people
yet
very untrustworthy um yeah max weinberg
invited me i don't know how i ended up
but um
he's a
[Applause]
pervert so yeah they've got like weird
celebrities that we've never heard of
over here like in in britain they're
like like these strange like they all
have children's names like they all like
they're called like bitsy and gemma and
emma right right and like
tommy and tini and like they have crazy
names and you're like why am i reading
and magazine that's right i still read
them but it's like you know you know
gugu and bibi make the scene and it's
these two people you know holding hands
and you're supposed to just be flipped
out about it but i don't know who they
are yeah and even if you have a regular
name like they'll make your name into
something like weird that sounds like a
child's name like if you were like a big
celebrity in england not that you're not
i'm sure you are
that was scary for a second
i'm huge in norway huge
you'd be like you'd be like cones yeah
so if you like we're hanging out with
madonna it'd be like cones and madge hit
the they call her yeah they call her
madge right right for some reason i want
to be cones here in america i think that
would be cool
i'm working on that